what's up loved it loved braving
unfortunate last night and everyone
about it what do you think is the most
important thing about it and why I think
representation is extremely important
you know I think I keep thinking back to
my ten year old self and you know what I
didn't have to look at or in films you
know in television and what I didn't
really see you know you know pretending
to be characters that look nothing like
me you know honestly you know for the
next generation being able to see
themselves in positions of power royalty
strength you know powerful women strong
characters smart intelligent and I think
the rep that's extremely important you
know I think I think that's one of the
you know important parts and sense of
identity sense of culture sense of like
who you are and your heritage I think is
super important as well so you know that
there's and not just you know for
African African Americans I'm talking
about you know everybody you know I just
got back from South Asia I mean from
from South Korea
you know seeing the reporters and
journalists come in and they were
traditional guards really from Malaysia
Indonesia and they just felt so
empowered they felt like they wanted to
represent their own heritage and that
was awesome so if somebody can see that
and feel comfortable and proud of where
you come from I think that super
important and speaking of women yep this
series in this and I felt really
empowered and like inspired watching
them and if you could pick one woman who
isn't related to you who you really feel
has been like a hero T in your life who
would it be this is this is woman who's
she's like family that his account uh
she's she's like family but she's known
me for a really long time but she she
she really helps me develop Who I am you
know she's almost you know a life coach
a coach of sorts but the spiritual
Conner yeah she's an amazing person and
and definitely been you know I mentor
and somebody I look up to and definitely
no checks me she holds a mirror up to my
face and you know and
and it allows me to check myself so I
think she's extremely important to me
great well thank you so much
lovely sweet nice to meet you too
you